-It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"! Here we go!
-♪ It's "The Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every night
until Christmas break,
we're giving away
an awesome gift
to every single person
in our studio audience.
And we saved
the biggest gift for last.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Questlove,
can I get a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Tonight's Stocking Stuffer is...
a SONDORS Smart Step
ReCycled e-bike!
Higgins.
-That's right, Jimmy.
SONDORS refurbished Smart Step
is an easygoing e-bike
delivering convenient
design, tech, and performance,
while happy to maintain
a greener future
by keeping them out of
the landfills.
With its
easy-step-through frame,
the SONDORS
refurbished smart bike
is as fun as
it is effortless to ride.
Jimmy!
-Everyone's getting an e-bike!
Everyone's getting an e-bike!
Thank you, SONDORS!
Enjoy your gifts, everybody!
We'll be right back with more of
"The Tonight Show"!